انا زعلانه كثير
عشان ماما
وبابا اسمي بسنت رافه اللوح عمري 16 سنه
كنا قاعدين وكنا مع بعض اسره جميله وحلوه
فجاه لقيت حالي في المستشفى كنت قاعده على
السرير اللي هم حكوا ما تحكها ما تحكها
بحكي لهم شو ما تحكها لو بحكي ابوك استشهد
وماما وبابا كثير حنونين علي الحمد لله
كانت امي وضعها صعب كثير وخطير الحمد لله
ما ودعت ابويا بس ودعت امي كانت صدمه
كبيره كبيره بحكي امي هلقيت هي الام
والابو بس هلقيت لا ام ولا
ابو جوزي كان مقاوم ولا له اي اي شي من
السياسه كان رايح يجيب لهم سطحين عشان
ياكلوا ظلهم ارين ا من 20 يوم عنده كان لا
خبز ولا اكل ولا اي شي كان كل شي في
حياتنا كان هو عمود الدار هو ضحكه بال
الدار نور الدار وان ل اللحظه هي كمان انه
مش في الصوره كان بدي ارجع على الدار وانا
مش وهو مش في
البيت اسمي ولاء عمري تسع سنين ده القضف
فحنا قاعدين بنتخ وبنضحك
فهذا ماما استشهدت وقعت على رجل اخويا
فمحمود اخوي كان يسر ويموت مش عارف شو بده
يسوي بدونها انا شفت ماما و مستشهد
وطلعوها قدامي محتاجه ماما كثير كنت كانت
كل يوم تواعدني اذا خلص الحرب طش شك وهذا
وكنت مبسوطه بس لما لما استشهدت زعلت كثير
كثير
كثير انا اسمي دلال ابو القمصان وعمري
ثمان سنين قصفوا
بيتنا
فوقينا و
وماما وماما استشهدت بالغرفه اللي فيها
القصف
و وقعد وقعدت اعيط عليها كانت
تعمللنا اكل وكنا نطلع احنا
وياها وبابا كنا نطلع اخويا لما يحكي وين
ماما بقول بالمستشفى بحكي لهم ماما
استشهدت بقول لي بالمستشفى اشتقت لها كثير
عشان اخوي كل يوم بزين وبده
اياها انا اسمي ديما وعمري 11 سنه كنا
بالصف وينين اللي هو
صار ظ الصف اللي جنبنا استشهد بابا
واستشهد ماما استشهدت ماما
واستشهد استشهدوا اخ اخوا
بدك سياره بنته كان نفسها تكمل واحده
دكتوره تصير وقول لها عشان اجي يابتع
الجيني وبنته الثانيه بتقول له انا بدي
افوم محميه ابني الصغير كان يقول له بدي
اروح اكمل عشان اصير بالجامعه كان فرحان
عبنا خالصه لما نعملوا له حفله توجيهي
يقول له امسوا تعملوا لي زي هيك يابا قال
له انا بدي اعملها ككر من هيك
يابا اللي بقى بده يعملهم ط الاحضر اه
ايش كان يعمل